notre invité jean-claude de samui et
bonjour je vous remercie de répondre à
france 24 vous êtes vice président
d'amnesty international france votre
travail c'est de documenter les
violations du droit international
c'est de rassembler des preuves de
rassembler aussi des témoignages
des photos quels sont vos informations
d'abord sur bocsa alors notre travail
effectivement amnesty international
c'est notre mission c'est de ces de
défense des droits humains et en
l'occurrence le droit international
humanitaire le droit de la guerre et
depuis le 24 février depuis le début de
cette agression
nous équipes documente à la fois sur le
terrain et à la fois dans le laboratoire
de de preuves en grandissant ciel toutes
les informations qui peuvent collecter
qui peut qui sont constitutifs de crimes
de guerre c'est à dire les bombardements
aveugles les bombardements délibérées
contre des infrastructures civiles les
le siège 1 le siège en tant que tel et
tu est une violation du droit du droit
humanitaire international puisque on
affame les populations leur coupent
l'électricité le gaz donc toutes ces
informations nous les collectons nous
les authentifiant nous les recoupements
et un jour nous les remettrons la
justice internationale vraisemblablement
la la la cour pénale internationale mais
peut-être parfois des états qui use de
la compétence universelle pour
poursuivre les auteurs de ces crimes
majeurs sur vous de chalets les images
sont terrifiantes on a vu notamment des
des hommes des civils exécutés avec les
mains et les jambes ligoté ça ce sont
des crimes de guerre ce sont nous sommes
en train d'authentifier toutes les
informations que nous collectons à bout
de chahains aujourd'hui amnesty vous
savez qu'on travaille que sur nos
propres recherches donc nous sommes en
train d'authentifier toutes les
informations qui nous remontent de butch
à fédérer dont vous serez d'événements
des crimes de guerre dont vous avez des
équipes à bout de chat qui aujourd'hui
sont dans dans cette région et qui
enquête qui enquête qui prennent des
photos qui recueille les témoignages qui
recoupe toutes les informations et qui
recoupe les informations que ce qui skie
avec notre laboratoire de l'analyse de
preuves parce qu'il faut vraiment qu'on
soit certain qu'il y a qui a la
responsabilité contre certaines la
responsabilité de ces crimes majeurs en
droit international comment est ce qu'on
fait pour remonter le fil de la
responsabilité moscou 10 voilà ce n'est
pas lille des cartes toute
responsabilité comment est ce qu'on fait
pour connaître l'identité des criminels
sans être accusé de partialité alors
effectivement nous sommes coup
totalement impartiaux et nous y tenons
c'est pour ça que nous prenons peut-être
un peu de temps pour authentifier toutes
ses preuves mais nous saurons quelle
bataille on était à bout tchad qu'el
commandante commandait le bataillon de
quelles armes et dépend des deux quais
les chefs d'état major et dépend des
dons nous remonterons petit à petit la
chaîne des responsabilités
mais nous encore une fois nous prenons
le temps d'authentifier toutes ses
responsabilités et toutes les preuves
que nous pouvons collectées sur terre
donc ça va prendre des semaines voire
des mois ça va prendre des semaines le
ça va prendre des semaines mais nous
encore une fois nous assistons pour que
ces preuves soient fiables parce
qu'elles seront remises à la cour pénale
internationale et ses preuves donc passe
par un laboratoire qui est extérieur à
l'ukraine indépendant et il fait quoi
cela lancés qu'en laboratoire qui dépend
d'un essai international qui qui fait de
la géolocalisation c'est à dire toutes
les informations que nous recevons ils
vont vérifier on va vérifier que c'est
la bonne date que ça s'est produit on va
vérifier que c'est dans telle ou telle
ville dans tel ou tel croisement sur
telle ou telle route il faut qu'on
identifie tout ça et puis nous avons des
experts en balistique qui vont
déterminer en analysant des fragments de
munitions qu'il s'agit de de munitions
interdites par le droit international
tels que les les les bons va souvent à
fragmentation les bombes à
sous-munitions kiki camp d impact
terrible sur les populations civiles
donc on analyse tous ces fragments de
munitions alors jean-claude samui et je
vous coupe le croit qui on a une
intervention en ce moment en direct le
maire de marioupol est en train de
s'exprimer si on peut me confirmer en
régie parce que je ne vois aucune image
le maire de rome mario paul donc cette
ville qui est constamment bombardée
depuis le début de la guerre il aurait
160 mille civils je crois qu'ils sont
prises au piège le maire de mario paul
est il là le maire le baril open je ne
le vois pas
personne en régie peut-être continuer
alors en continu jean-claude samui et
donc sur cette enquête qui est vraiment
très précises on voit très longue et
minutieuse comment est ce que vous vous
collaborez avec les autres ong puisqu'il
y à d'autres ong et d'autres
associations il ya aussi l'état
ukrainien qui enquêtent comment est ce
que vous faites et nous demandons-nous
amnesty international nous demandons aux
états la communauté internationale de
collaborer avec la cour pénale
internationale pour justement lui donner
les moyens de collecter et de lui donner
des effets des d'épreuves faut qu'elle
même puissent mener son enquête donc
c'est un travail en commun si je puis
dire non t'aurais pas tous on note tout
seul dans notre coin il faut absolument
réunir suffisamment de preuves pour
poursuivre les auteurs de ces crimes de
guerre pourquoi ça passera forcément par
la cour pénale internationale et pas par
la justice ukrainienne ça peut passer
par les juges les ukrainiens ça peut
passer par la cour pénale internationale
ne peut pas passer par les tribunaux des
différents états au titre de la
compétence universelle on sait que et un
certain nombre de conventions qui
permettent et qui je dirais qu'ils
m'aiment rendre obligatoire la poursuite
des personnes par les états les
personnes qui sont présumés coupables
des crimes majeurs les crimes de torture
les crimes de guerre les crimes de
génocide les crimes contre l'humanité
non qu'ils aient tout un tas de doughty
qui devrait permettre à la justice de
passer et de
fixer les responsabilités de poursuivre
et de juger les auteurs le président
ukrainien le président volodymyr
zelensky veut un mécanisme spécial pour
enquêter est ce que vous comprenez ce
que ça veut dire concrètement nous
comprenons ce que ça veut dire mais nous
prenons pas position là dessus nous ce
que nous souhaitons c'est que la justice
internationale passe il ya différents et
différents outils qui existent utilisons
ces outils nous ne prenons pas position
sur l'initiative de l'ukrainienne mais
l'essentiel c'est que les auteurs soient
qu'une qu'on lutte contre l'impunité si
on avait poursuivi les auteurs des
crimes de guerre en tchétchénie comme le
city tout à l'heure où en syrie on n'en
serait peut-être pas là aujourd'hui en
ukraine donc on travaille pour l'avenir
même si le temps de la justice est un
peu différent du temps des bombes il
faut qu'on prépare l'avenir et qu'on
empêche le que ses autres sites et se
renouvellent temps de l'émotion aussi
qui est important il ya le temps de
l'émotion qui est important aussi vous
parler de la syrie vous avez enquêté sur
les crimes de bachar al assad et des
russes est ce que vous voyez des
similitudes avec
les similitudes c'est prendre les
populations civiles en otage alors que
le droit de la guerre distingue les
objectifs unités à des objectifs civils
a enfin le droit de la guerre un qui
repose sur la protection des civils
justement et c'est le même mode
opératoire qui a été utilisée est unique
et utilisant si rick et utilise en
ukraine s'est martyrisé terroriser les
populations et les anéantir
il n'y a pas eu de procès autour de la
syrie à la norme pénale internationale
pour quelle raison parce que la syrie
n'avait pas signé le traité de rome et
la russie d'ailleurs alors que l'ukraine
n'a pas signé le traité de rome qui
porte création de la cour pénale
internationale mais reconnaît la
compétence de la cour pénale
internationale sur son territoire ce qui
nous permettra d'avancer entamé justice
vous avez bon espoir d'un procès un jour
il faudra un procès un jour est-ce qu'il
ya d'autres exactions d'autres crimes de
guerre que vous avez des noms dénoncé en
ukraine au delà de boudhha oui on a
documenté à perpignan la commenter
kharkiv à caractère qui kiffent à ''se
jum chaque fois ci elle même c'est le
même mode opératoire on encercle la
ville ont coupé l'électricité on coupe
le gaz on coupe les accès des des ong
humanitaires c'est à dire que les gens
n'ont plus de rien à manger non plus
d'eau potable non plus de médicaments il
ya beaucoup de personnes qui décèdent
parce qu'elles vivent dans des caves
dans des situations épouvantables
donc tout ça est documenté et amnesty
international puis par d'autres ong par
d'autres journalistes merci infiniment
jean-claude samui et vice président
d'amnesty international merci on